last question today hey David will a
more crowded Democratic primary help the
more progressive candidates in that
primary like Elizabeth Warren and
potentially Bernie Sanders so that
there's a couple ways to approach this
primary voters are often more
politically diverse than general
election voters but right now the
circumstances are those of a very
significant overlap between candidates a
lot of the candidate ranking sites
aren't even on the same page as to who
is the most left or center in the
Democratic primary one example of that
is that the I side with I side with is a
website that has a pretty good quiz that
it asks you about your politics and then
it tells you who are you closest to it
labels Kirsten Gillibrand as more of a
socialist for example which I just don't
think is accurate I don't know of any
way that that we would defend Kirsten
Gillibrand politics is socialistic in
any way so number one you have
circumstances where you have a ton of
overlap between candidates what is the
real difference in policy between
Gillibrand and Julian Castro for example
are they really big differences or are
they relatively minor Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie for example if you were to
run are there how significant are the
difference is there I spoke about that
on the Monday show with Benjamin
Studebaker and there are differences and
there excuse me as I punch my mic their
approaches are different but they end up
pretty similar on policy so I am NOT
saying this to suggest that in the end
we should just go with the person who
can build the biggest coalition because
those are exactly the types of
electability games that I want to avoid
playing but what I am saying is it's not
clear to me that more candidates
particularly when they overlap so much
will be in any significant way better
for the more progressive candidates I do
think that will the more progressive
candidates will be held back to some
degree if they are from the northeast of
the United States and again I'm starting
to sort of get into these electability
games but that is going to be more of a
liability
being more to the left because the
elected officials in the Democratic
Party are pretty significantly to the
right of where Democratic voters are on
issues related to economic equality
health care the minimum wage on so many
different issues the electorate is
already to the left of democratic
elected officials so I think that the
smear possibilities as being out of
touch northeastern liberals if those
happen to be the more progressive
candidates and I think you understand
what I'm sort of getting at is going to
be the biggest liability but I'm
answering the question I'm trying to
avoid playing these electability games
overall when the field is more and more
crowded merely mathematically
particularly when a lot of the
candidates are similar it just splits
the vote but more ways right I mentioned
Castro and Gillibrand Warren and Bernie
is another possibility although
ideologically they come from different
backgrounds so the vote splitting
potential is one that can be very
difficult to predict who it will
actually help in the net and only time
will tell at this point but to answer
the question I don't think that tons of
candidates benefits the more progressive
2020 Democratic candidates send me your
thoughts we've got a great bonus show
for you today we're going to talk about
very very exciting and interesting
stories although I'm out of time to tell
you what they are
I've become a member at WWN pakman.com
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show - get instant access
to the world-famous bonus show